[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines au programme de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici les titres de ce
lundi 27 mars
[Musique]
la 17e édition des Journées Européennes
des Métiers d'Art ça démarre aujourd'hui
le but de faire découvrir ces métiers
manuels artisanaux souvent méconnus dans
les Yvelines plus d'une soixantaine
d'ateliers ouvrent leurs portes
rencontrent démonstration et expositions
sont à l'honneur TV 78 vous présente
plusieurs portraits d'artisans ce soir
rencontre avec un affuteur rémouleur
yvelinois
décollage imminent deux ans après le
lancement du premier nano satellite
conçu au l'Atmos c'est au tour de
l'inspire 7 seven de bientôt rejoindre
les étoiles des diales observation de la
terre et du soleil il partira le 9 avril
prochain nous en parlerons avec notre
invité Mustapha Meftah chercheur au
laboratoire atmosphère et observation
spatiale basée à Guyancourt et enfin
préparez-vous à swinguer dans les
Yvelines la National Golf 8 revient pour
une deuxième édition au Golf National
cette semaine c'est du 30 mars au 1er
avril et au programme compétition salon
et animations
et ce sera avec Antoine Robin qui nous
rejoindra dans quelques dans quelques
instants pour en parler dans notre
partie sport et avec vous la partie
sport mikaemi Doro bonsoir de quoi
allons nous parler aujourd'hui alors on
va parler de plein de choses aujourd'hui
dans la partie sport on va parler
notamment football et du match nul de
Versailles contre chauléon parla
également football mais de première
division de district avec la belle
victoire de Bailly Noisy sur le terrain
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux de 1 nous
parlerons aussi de la Guyancourt une
course qui s'est déroulée ce week-end à
Guyancourt et d'une compétition de
billard à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
dans quelques instants et en fait de
vous Mustapha Mesta bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chercheur ou l'Atmos le laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines elles étaient
également le coordinateur des projets de
nano-satellite comme je le disais dans
les titres un nouveau nano satellite
partira le 9 avril prochain de la base
américaine en Californie à Vandenberg et
nous sommes justement aujourd'hui à
moins de deux semaines du lancement il
devait initialement partir en janvier
puis il a été décalé au 3 avril et
maintenant le 9 pourquoi tous ces
reports alors un lancement c'est
toujours quelque chose de complexe ça ne
dépend pas de nous donc on passe nous
par le l'autorité de lancement qui
s'appelle Space X donc le lanceur comme
vous l'avez dit c'est pas le code nine
pas le code 9 on voit ici une maquette à
échelle incendieme qui montre la chose
et ces reports sont liés à un des
problèmes parfois techniques sur le
lanceur lui-même ou au vu de la
situation actuelle comme nous partons
depuis une base militaire il peut y
avoir des lancements de satellites
gouvernementaux militaire qui peuvent
prendre le dessus on en parlera plus
longuement dans quelques instants au
programme également au cours de la
prochaine heure nous partirons à la
rencontre d'étudiants à l'école ESTACA
cette école d'ingénieur basée à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ces derniers ont
présenté leurs projets associatifs des
projets qui portent sur la mobilité du
futur et pour terminer cette édition
vous découvrirez également le portrait
de merylocket grâce au sport ce para
athlète à voyagé dans de nombreux pays
du monde à Bali l'île de la Réunion
encore en Ouganda il se confie sur le
regard porté sur le handicap à travers
le monde donc voilà le programme est
découle est déroulé mais juste avant ça
je vous propose de jeter un œil sur les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
le ciel sera voilé dans la matinée de
mardi sur l'ensemble du territoire
yvinois côté température il fera 4
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et 3 degrés à
Houdan Rambouillet et Versailles dans
l'après-midi le temps se dégrade le ciel
sera très nuageux mais le thermostat
grimpe il fera 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 11 degrés sur le
reste de du territoire et ce mardi 28
mars sera la saint Gontran tout de suite
le point sur les informations du jour
dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
sans le chiffre du jour 100 km de piste
cyclables vont être déployés pour relier
les sites olympiques de Paris 2024 dans
le département le Comité olympique des
Yvelines vient d'acter cette réalisation
décision à laquelle a participé Amélie
ou des à Castera la ministre des Sports
c'est d'ailleurs rendu vendredi sur la
colline des longs courts lieu des
épreuves de VTT ou des travaux
d'aménagement sont en cours pour rappel
4 sites des Yvelines accueilleront des
épreuves durant les prochains jeux
olympiques les syndicats appellent à une
dixième journée de mobilisation demain
mardi contre la réforme des retraites de
nombreux secteurs seront de nouveau
impactés dans les Yvelines prévoir en
moyenne un train sur deux sur les RER A
et B et la ligne N deux trains sur 3 sur
les lignes JL et U et intrins sur 3 sur
le RER C du côté de l'enseignement des
perturbations sont attendues dans les
écoles les collèges et les lycées mais
aussi dans les accueils périscolaires et
les services des cantines après
l'utilisation par le gouvernement de
l'article 49-3 pour faire adopter la
réforme des retraites plusieurs élus ont
révélé avoir été visés par des menaces
c'est le cas dans les Yvelines de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique]
l'enquête complète est disponible sur le
site du monde un corps découvert ce
dimanche dans une maison squattée à
Mantes-la-Jolie le raid est intervenu
dans le quartier des martres pour
interpeller des individus présumés armés
retranchés dans cette habitation deux
hommes y aurait été séquestrés dont l'un
de retrouver mort après l'assaut du Raid
la victime chez par balle était âgée de
25 ans et n'a pu être identifié pour le
moment un important arsenal d'armes et
de munitions a été également saisi sur
place le sans-abri qui a donné l'alerte
et entendu par les forces de l'ordre
l'enquête est confiée à la police
judiciaire de Versailles et puis plus
d'une espèce sur trois serait menacée
dans le monde le dernier hors série de
Science et Vie et découvertes qui vient
de paraître ankiosque s'intéresse aux
animaux à protéger 40 espèces sont mises
en lumière dans les 148 pages du numéro
toutes présentes aux eaux safari de
Thoiry qui s'est associé au magazine
pour ce hors-série l'objectif éduqué et
sensibiliser à la protection de la
biodiversité
[Musique]
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
êtes témoin d'un fait qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à le
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
faire entretenir ses outils plutôt que
de le jeter quels sont le lait motifs de
rudimentini un affuteur rémouleur
inhymontant après une carrière dans une
société du CAC 40 il lance son
auto-entreprise et filiforme à l'âge de
50 ans avec son atelier itinérant il se
déplace dans les Yvelines chez les
particuliers et les professionnels un
reportage signé Julien Leroy un nouveau
départ pour rudimentini s'est affuteur
rémouleur originaire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux a lancé en
octobre 2022 sa micro-entreprise et
filiforme au volant de sa camionnette
l'artisan parcourt le département pour
entretenir couteau ciseau sécateur aucun
outil ne résiste à son regard à guiser
de la lame
une pâte d'affûtage sur ce marché de
noflux le château l'entrepreneur
travaille à bord de son atelier
itinérant un geste de précision
redonnant son tranchant à l'outil pour
prolonger sa durée de vie quand le
taillant commence à être un petit peu
usé à ce moment-là il faut faire ce
qu'on appelle un aiguisage donc ça se
fait aussi sur un fusil donc là on a un
fusil avec un grain extra-fin etc et
puis quand vraiment notamment les
boucher vont vraiment se faire de
manière intensive de leur de leur
couteau au bout d'un moment donc les
visages ne suffit plus donc il faut à
nouveau affûté ça c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est des métiers dont je me souviens
quand j'étais enfant et qui ont disparu
au fil du temps ou donc on a été pendant
pas mal de temps obligé de racheter du
matériel neuf à chaque fois alors que
maintenant bah ça va permettre de de
réutiliser du matériel et d'éviter donc
du gâchis du gaspillage son grand-père
bouché lui transmet la passion de
l'affûtage dès le plus jeune âge après
26 ans passés dans une grande entreprise
du CAC 40 comme responsable des services
généraux rudiment décide de se
reconvertir à l'âge de 50 ans la plupart
de la de ma confession je travaille dans
les bureaux où j'allais sur les
chantiers mais je regardais j'en
travaillais et puis plutôt que de faire
travailler les autres j'en ai envie de
travailler moi-même de revenir un petit
peu au fondamentaux aux choses simples
et puis surtout être en contact avec les
clients le client final il semble déjà
bien affûté
plein de papiers mais quand même tissu
d'accord il y a des gens qui viennent
comme on évoquait tout à l'heure qu'on
est des outils parfois avec une charge
affective importante donc c'est vraiment
le voir le sourire des gens quand on
leur rend le leur matériel futé
améliorer etc donc voilà c'est ça
vraiment ça me c'est quelque chose qui
me fait plaisir la future rémouleur
cherche à développer son activité auprès
des professionnels bouchées couturières
ou encore quoi faire font partie de ces
cibles pour pérenniser son activité
itinérante ah très bien très bien
ça va mieux marcher là ça va mieux
fonctionner
alors vous l'avez vu c'est un sujet
diffusé dans le cadre des Journées
européennes des métiers d'art et chaque
semaine et chaque jour cette semaine
nous vous diffuserons un sujet sur cette
thématique on en parlerait on en parle
on en parlait en début d'émission un
deuxième nano satellite sera mis en
orbite le 9 avril prochain il a été
conçu au l'Atmos le laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale à
Guyancourt et il partira en Californie à
bord du Falcon name de la société SpaceX
alors pour en parler avec nous Mustapha
mefta ma première question est la
suivante quelle sera la mission de
l'inspire 7 seven alors iSpy
va avoir plusieurs objectifs donc le
premier c'est d'observer la terre donc
on va s'intéresser aux déséquilibres
énergétique de la planète donc on va
faire des multi-observations depuis
l'espace on va aussi s'intéresser à
l'état de l'ionosphère c'est une des
couches de l'atmosphère qui peut
notamment avoir des impacts sur les
communications on voit aussi en profiter
pour valider des éléments technologiques
pour préparer les futures missions
spatiales et enfin nous avons aussi à
bord une charge utile qui a été
développée par les radios amateurs alors
un Guyancourt il y a un club
radioamateur qui s'appelle f6k RK donc
c'est aussi donner la possibilité à des
radios amateurs de pouvoir utiliser
l'espace pour pouvoir communiquer depuis
le sol et qu'est-ce qu'on appelle une
charge utile alors une charge utile
c'est comme pour un véhicule vous avez
le véhicule c'est la plateforme donc sur
un site satellite nous avons la
plateforme et la charge utile ce sont
les passagers ou les bagages donc pour
un satellite ce sont les instruments qui
vont permettre de faire les mesures et
justement c'est une anneau satellite il
part pour combien de temps exactement
alors nous nous avons fait nos calculs
pour que la durée de vie soit de moins 4
années donc logiquement nous sommes
partis pour 4 ans de bonheurs et comment
ça fonctionne exactement alors on peut
le voir à l'écran est-ce de quoi est-ce
que ce composent cet instrument ce
satellite ou l'instrument alors le
satellite se compose de plusieurs
instruments j'imagine alors comme vous
pouvez le voir sur la vidéo sur l'image
donc le satellite est constitué de
plusieurs instruments donc il y a
plusieurs détecteurs qui sont
miniaturisés et c'est détecteurs
miniaturisés vont permettre justement de
répondre aux questions énoncées
précédemment typiquement on voit les
petits carrés blancs qui correspondent à
des électeurs de flux à partir de ces
éléments nous pouvons mesurer ce qui est
mis par la planète et la transmission de
la communication entre la Terre et entre
le Nano satellite et
la terre alors on doit passer par ces
petites antennes que l'on voit aussi au
niveau du satellite donc le satellite va
émettre un signal audio et au sol avec
un réseau d'antenne au sol nous allons
récupérer les informations et justement
ce lancement se fait dans le cadre de la
mission transporteur seven de la société
SpaceX est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus alors
SpaceX propose une solution c'est aussi
le cas d'Arianespace nous aurions
préféré partir avec Arianespace
évidemment mais au vu du calendrier nous
avons choisi SpaceX donc transporteur 7
c'est pour embarquer plusieurs petits
satellites donc logiquement une centaine
de satellites vont être à bord de ce
lanceur et vont être déployés à une
altitude d'environ 500 km sur une orbite
polaire et vous aviez dit plusieurs
satellites là on est en phase de nous un
anneau satellite c'est ce que vous
pouvez aussi nous expliquer nous décrire
qu'est-ce que c'est exactement un anneau
satellite
c'est comme un satellite classique sauf
qu'on leur utilise le mot nano parce
qu'il est plus petit donc nous avons les
mêmes fonctions à l'extérieur nous
voyons les cellules solaires qui
permettent d'absorber donc le
rayonnement solaire pour pouvoir
apporter l'énergie électrique pour
alimenter l'ensemble du satellite donc
nous allons avoir aussi des batteries un
ordinateur de bord pour faire la
communication avec le les autres cartes
électroniques une carte de
radiocommunication et les détecteurs
eux-mêmes donc nous sommes sur un
satellite classique sauf que l'échelle
l'échelle est miniaturisée et combien de
temps ce que vous avez mis à le
concevoir son anneau satellite quels ont
été les grandes étapes alors nous avons
mis deux années donc les grandes étapes
c'est d'abord développer l'idée donc
partir d'une idée scientifique dans nos
thématiques de recherche ensuite c'est
faire sa conception donc c'est pour cela
que nous avons l'aide de plusieurs
étudiants notamment de l'ESTACA
et ensuite une fois que nous avons fait
sa définition nous allons le fabriquer
et ensuite après avoir fabriqué ce
satellite nous allons le tester donc à
Guyancourt nous avons une plateforme de
test qui s'appelle la piste la
plateforme de test de Guyancourt nous
faisons tous les essais pour vérifier
que le satellite va bien
respecter les niveaux qu'il verra lors
du lancement lui-même mais aussi les
effets de température en orbite voilà
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes à la
dernière étape le satellite est intégré
sous la coiffe
bientôt nous allons voir le lanceur qui
doit il va s'élever et donc nous allons
avoir un lancement qui est prévu le 9
avril 2023 et justement vous l'aviez dit
tout à l'heure c'est un projet à viser
scientifique mais c'est aussi un projet
avec des étudiants ce que vous pouvez
revenir un peu plus en détail dessus
comment ça s'est déroulé alors c'est
aussi un projet qui a trois composantes
donc la première c'est la partie
recherche associée à nos thématiques le
deuxième aspect c'est la validation
technologique d'éléments en orbite et
enfin la composante pédagogique alors
l'idée c'est de développer ces
instruments et ses satellites aussi avec
les étudiants parce que on peut les
préparer au métier futur et quand on
développe un satellite nous avons tous
les métiers tous les métiers de
l'ingénieur qui sont qui sont utilisés
nickel vous avez une question oui je
voulais savoir quelle est la différence
avec UVSQ sat qui est parti il y a
quelques années quelle est la différence
alors que ça t'a été mis en orbite le 24
janvier 2021 donc après deux ans nous
développons ce satellite déjà le volume
nous avons un satellite qui est deux
fois plus gros ensuite nous avons aussi
à qui de l'expérience car ce satellite
uvsqat nous a permis de mieux comprendre
certaines mesures observées donc nous
avons amélioré la performance du
satellite donc un effet incrémental et
enfin comme nous avons un satellite qui
est plus gros nous avons intégré de
nouvelles missions scientifiques et
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait à vous de
voir votre nano satellite bientôt partir
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
personnellement
c'est toujours quelque part bon c'est
une fierté pour le laboratoire et pour
les équipes qui ont développé ce
programme parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup
d'équipes derrière nous qui font ce
programme et ensuite c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotions parce que il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'heures de travail et
donc en attendant avec impatience le
lendemain d'heures de travail sur ce
projet alors en général on raisonne
plutôt en équivalent temps plein
personne il faut considérer au moins une
dizaine de personnes
par an pendant au moins deux années
alors complètement satisfait parce que
UV Q7 ça durée de vie initiale c'était
une année et là ça fait plus de deux ans
qu'il est en orbite donc il est toujours
opérationnel donc vis-à-vis de sa durée
de vie c'est excellent et ensuite
vis-à-vis des résultats que nous avons
c'est aussi très bien parce que nous
avons déjà accumulé plus de 10 millions
de données donc nous arrivons à suivre
l'évolution des variables climatiques
qui nous intéressent avec une basse
résolution parce que on ne va pas faire
mieux avec un petit satellite que avec
un gros satellite par contre l'intérêt
de ces petits satellites c'est de les
utiliser en grappe d'en avoir plusieurs
donc l'idée avec ce deuxième satellite
c'est d'avoir deux points de mesure et
cela va nous permettre de diviser par
deux le temps de revisite parce qu'un
des paramètres qui est fondamental c'est
de pouvoir réobserver une scène avec une
fréquence plus importante
et aussi ce que vous avez prévu de
partir en Californie pour le lancement
alors non parce que c'est sur une base
militaire donc j'avais évidemment une
place pour assister au lancement parce
qu'il y a toujours des places
particulières mais non parce que je vais
pas aller tout seul là-bas et de pour
des raisons aussi écologiques si vous
voulez
sans problème pour le prochain lancement
et le prochain satellite avec un
lancement prévu en 2025 j'espère ce
matin on a aussi appris une actualité il
y aurait cinq planètes qui sont alignées
depuis dimanche est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez aussi observer
honnêtemos alors avec d'autres
instruments oui c'est possible mais un
satellite qui est en orbite basse lui se
focaliserait essentiellement sur la
planète Terre mais aussi le soleil donc
oui nous pouvons mais pas avec un
satellite
et vous avez également publié donc ce
livre l'espace et le new space au
service du climat qui est sorti cette
année c'est
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
là-dessus alors oui je peux vous en dire
là l'idée c'est de présenter un peu la
situation vis-à-vis de la conquête
spatiale donc depuis quelques années
nous avons basculé dans une nouvelle ère
certains appellent cela le new space
d'autres le Next space donc j'essaie de
décrire ce phénomène et enfin au travers
du livre je te montrer l'importance de
l'observation de la Terre notamment avec
des satellites pour avoir un meilleur
état de la situation notamment vis-à-vis
du réchauffement climatique donc l'idée
c'est d'utiliser les satellites comme
vigie du climat pour pouvoir répondre
aux enjeux environnementaux et
écologiques qui sont à des enjeux
majeurs du 21e siècle et bien merci
Mustapha mefta d'être venu en plateau
pour en parler avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes chercheur olattmos au
laboratoire qui a conçu le Nano
satellite inspire 7 seven kit décollera
ou qui sera mis en orbite le 9 avril
prochain pour rester dans cette
thématique d'innovation Michel et le
midoro vous êtes parti avec l'un des
journalistes de la rédaction TV 78
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude à l'ESTACA
donc il y a quelques jours l'école
d'ingénieur a présenté les projets
associatifs de ces étudiants des travaux
qui concernent la mobilité du futur on
regarde
nous sommes à la journée à des
associations ESTACA à mes côtés
Catherine qui est présente ce jeudi 16
mars pour cette journée un petit peu
particulière ici à l'ESTACA c'est une
grande première Catherine tout à fait
c'est l'idée c'est de présenter les
projets associatifs assez variés comme
vous pouvez le voir qui ont lieu à
l'ESTACA aux partenaire pour les
associations de manière à ce qu'elles
puissent donner la visibilité aux
entreprises qui les connaissent pas
forcément et éventuellement trouver des
sponsors oui trouver des sponsors c'est
un petit peu l'essence même de l'ESTACA
c'est important de attirer de nouveaux
sponsors pour pouvoir développer des
projets peut-être encore plus gros et
plus important alors tout à fait vous
allez le voir ils ont quand même
développé des projets qui participent à
des compétitions donc c'est des projets
technologiques qui nécessitent
évidemment des budgets assez importants
donc c'est important qu'ils aient des
sponsors suffisants pour pouvoir
développer les technologies qu'ils
souhaitent et innover qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve par exemple on voit qu'il y a
des projets quand même assez typique on
a vu R2D2 il y a quelques instants Droid
qui a été créé par les élèves il y a
aussi des mécaniques ici qu'est-ce qu'on
peut retrouver alors on trouve des
projets qui reflètent un petit peu les
différentes filières de l'école c'est à
dire vous allez des projets en
automobile alors par exemple le véhicule
de la énergétique de la PV 3e ou le
véhicule qui concourt à la formulation
chaque année on trouve des projets
plutôt dans le domaine naval on trouve
des projets spatiaux c'est à dire qu'on
a des étudiants qui conçoivent et
construisent des fusées qui vont
décoller chaque année dans le cadre
d'une compétition étudiante organisée
par le CNES on a des projets côté
ferroviaires bien sûr on a des projets
comme vous l'avez vu du côté de tout ce
qui est robotique voilà donc ça couvre
l'ensemble des filières qui sont
présentes à l'ESTACA ces associations
c'est vraiment très important pour les
stackards alors pour nous c'est
essentiel parce que tout ce qui se passe
sur les bancs de l'école évidemment
c'est important mais toutes les
compétences qui sont acquises dans un
cadre associatif c'est tout à fait
formateur aussi sur dans le cadre
associatif on apprend à gérer un projet
on apprend à gérer un budget on apprend
à travailler en équipe on apprend à
avoir des délais à respecter des cahiers
des charges et tout ça c'est aussi très
formateur et les entreprises qui
recrutent nos diplômés nous le disent
très régulièrement pour eux tout ce
qu'ils ont appris à l'école dans le
cadre académique c'est évidemment très
bien mais c'est un vrai plus que d'avoir
des compétences acquises dans des
projets concrets comme dans le cas des
projets associatifs si je comprends bien
il y a l'école et après il y a les
associations il y a quand même l'école
qui est très importante bien sûr et il
faut savoir que même dans le cadre
académique certains projets proposés par
les associations peuvent entrer dans le
garde du cursus c'est à dire que il y a
des études technologiques qui sont
intégrés à l'intérieur même du programme
académique donc voilà donc c'est
vraiment pour nous c'est un tout et
c'est pour ça que l'école encourage
vraiment les étudiants à s'investir dans
dans la vie associative parce qu'on sait
que c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée tous
les élèves présents ici à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux font partie d'une
association alors tous peut-être pas une
très grande majorité à peu près ou pas
vous donner un pourcentage mais vraiment
une majorité d'étudiants sont investis
dans les associations étudiantes est-ce
qu'il y a un projet en particulier qui
vous fascine
alors il y en a beaucoup qui me
fascinent on est on est en face de de la
formulation voilà on peut peut-être
parler de des stacca formulatif qui a un
nouveau projet qui a été présenté la
semaine dernière justement dévoilé le
nouveau véhicule a été dévoilé eux ils
participent chaque année à une grande
compétition internationale qui s'appelle
la Formula Student voilà donc ça c'est
un projet très innovant on a Enzo et ses
fusées qui sont là c'est également voilà
des étudiants qui travaillent toute
l'année pour concevoir leur fusée qui
vont décoller dans le cadre des
campagnes organisées par le CNES on
aille de Dway ce qui a une association
alors sur un une un secteur qui est
moins attractif qui est le ferroviaire
mais qui développe des très très beaux
projets qui montent des conférences en
alpdg de la SNCF qui va passer la
semaine dernière sur leur invitation
voilà donc il y a beaucoup
d'associations alors je vois le cercle
aéronautique aussi dont on n'a pas parlé
qui est une association dans le domaine
aéronautique de la formation pour les
étudiants qui veulent voilà se former et
pour devenir pilote amateur ils
organisent des rallyes aériens des
visites entreprises donc il y a vraiment
plein d'associations dans des domaines
très variés qui méritent notre
admiration toutes les personnes qui ont
des idées peuvent venir les stacks je
comprends bien ils peuvent venir à
l'ESTACA développer leurs idées ils sont
bienvenus on va aller maintenant voir
romain qui est responsable Fédération
des associations
[Musique]
nous sommes maintenant avec Romain qui
va tout nous expliquer sur cette
association qui est juste derrière moi
c'est Enzo alors Enzo qu'est-ce que
c'est Romain alors les os c'est l'ESTACA
space odyssey c'est une association qui
représente la filière spatiale de
l'école et son but c'est de travailler
sur des projets techniques qui font
grandir les élèves en termes de
compétences dans ce secteur là et donc
leur projet phare qui s'appelle le SL
les staccas Space launcher leur but
final en 2025 c'est de lancer une fusée
à 30 km de hauteur ça c'est novateur ou
pas comme association bah c'est clair
comme association étudiante réalisée de
tels c'est vraiment assez novateur il y
a d'autres
écoles d'autres université qui font des
projets de la même ampleur mais des
autres positionnent clairement comme une
grosse association dans le secteur
étudiant à peu près combien de personnes
à peu près dans cette association les
eaux je dirais qu'ils sont quasiment 200
voilà et comment ça se passe
concrètement quand on est étudiant ici
on va tout de suite en philosociations
dès que l'école est terminée mais on
voit que ce sont quand même des projets
gigantesques ça prend énormément de
temps bah c'est vrai qu'elle est Staka
il y a un engagement dans les
associations qui est très fort on a plus
de deux étudiants sur trois qui
participent à des projets entre la
première et la quatrième année donc les
étudiants sont globalement enfin très
investis et pas du temps en dehors des
cours et les week-ends
les projets qui s'appellent des
pépinières et
les associations passent leur temps
là-bas pour développer les différents
projets et qu'est-ce qui fait que ça
plaît justement de travailler dans une
association vous d'ailleurs vous avez
été à membre d'une association bah je
pense qu'il plaît à l'ESTACA et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a autant d'associations
c'est que l'environnement est très
propice il y a constamment des
événements et on se sent vraiment
toutes ces étudiants font partie d'une
équipe et je pense c'est ça qui est
motivé à travailler encore et encore et
quels sont les retours extérieurs sur
les associations
on a juste à voir le nombre de
partenaires de la plupart des
associations et les budgets qui sont mis
en jeu pour les différents projets pour
comprendre que
les associations à l'ESTACA c'est
quelque chose de vraiment majeur et
important et comme je l'ai dit le nombre
de partenaires c'est c'est quand même
assez important les eaux par exemple
c'est énormément de partenaire j'imagine
autour d'un projet comme celui-là c'est
énormément de partenaire et même des
gros partenaires comme Ariane comme
différents sites de lancement parce que
c'est vrai que ça demande des
infrastructures qui sont très grosses
pour lancer des fusées et donc
il se déplace au new space ou à l'Europe
par exemple pour pour lancer leur modèle
petite précision il faut obligatoirement
faire partie de l'ESTACA pour faire
partie d'une association on est d'accord
ça dépend des associations et de manière
générale non mais c'est vrai que pour
réaliser les projets et pour bénéficier
enfin de tous les avantages et de toutes
les conférences et de tout ce qui se
passe faut faire partie des steaks et
pour avoir plus de renseignements
j'imagine qu'il y a tout sur le site
internet de l'ESTACA il y a beaucoup
d'informations sur le site internet de
l'ESTACA chaque association a son site
internet derrière donc si vous voulez
vous renseigner sur les associations en
général allez sur le site de l'estacs 1
fr voilà donc deux tiers des étudiants
de l'ESTACA font partie des associations
et ils espèrent avoir de nombreux
partenaires dans les prochaines années
et c'est maintenant l'heure d'ouvrir une
page sport
[Musique]
et Antoine Robin nous a rejoint en
plateau pour venir nous parler de la
National Golf 8 bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous attendez beaucoup de personnes pour
cette deuxième édition oui effectivement
on attend plusieurs milliers de
personnes grâce à un temps qui sera plus
clément que la dernière édition donc on
va dire que ce sera notre première
édition dans des conditions tout à fait
normal donc on espère beaucoup de
visiteurs
on en parlera de plus en plus tout à
l'heure mais avant avec notre
journaliste sport Michaël elmidoro vous
allez nous parler des résultats sportifs
du week-end dans les Yvelines
l'actualité a été riche et on commence
par du football dans le championnat de
National 1 le FC Versailles a pu faire
mieux que match nul sur le terrain de
Cholet les Versailles se sont fait
rejoindre en fin de partie avec une
égalisation la 84e minute ils avaient
pourtant ouvert le score à la 48e minute
par Jordan Leborgne au classement les
joueurs de la cité royale sont pour
l'instant toujours premiers mais le
second Marty a un match en moi il faudra
se reprendre lundi prochain à domicile
contre Châteauroux et on descend de
quelques une division pour parler du
championnat de régional 2 plusieurs
clubs zivelinois jouaient ce week-end
trap n'a pu faire mieux que match nul
00 sur le terrain de adamoa Conflans a
perdu 1 à 0 sur la pelouse de Champigny
ou s'impose de à zéro contre Suresnes
contre La Garenne-Colombes 2 à 0 et
Argenteuil bat le FC Mantois de à zéro
classement où il est toujours leader
devant Conflans
et on va continuer à parler de football
et de l'un des chocs du week-end c'était
le choc de cette 16e journée du
championnat de D1 de district le voisin
FC recevait sur son terrain le Bailly
noisy dans un match en jeu pour la
monter ce sont finalement les visiteurs
qui ont remporté la partie le résumé du
match
un choc indien de district ce dimanche
26 mars le voisin FC en jaune recevait
bailler noisy les deux équipes dans le
top 5 du classement vice toujours la
montée en fin de saison dans ce match à
en jeu les joueurs locaux sont plus
dominateurs mais n'arrive pas à
concrétiser leurs occasions ils se font
finalement surprendre par les bleus sur
cette action 1 à 0 ce sera le score à la
pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
domine après on manque de tranchant dans
les 30 derniers mètres parce qu'on a les
situations sans grosse occasion au final
mais quand on a 80% de possession de
balle on peut pas se permettre de perdre
un zéro à la mi-temps tout simplement on
a pas le ballon ou pas et on est
solidaire on est bloque bas après je les
ai pas trouvé très dangereux à part sur
coup de pied arrêté et nous on est sorti
deux trois fois on marque on marque
avant la pose ça nous fait du bien et
après voilà on est dans la limite qu'on
fait depuis le début de saison au retour
des vestiaires les vicinois accélèrent
et trouvent la faille sur cette action
un partout de son côté Bailly noisy
subit dans cette seconde période et
terminera la rencontre à 10 après une
expulsion en infériorité numérique et
sur le point de plier les visiteurs
arrivent à se projeter vers l'avant en
fin de match sur cette action et Marc
score final de 1
[Musique]
en gros soulagement on a subi un
deuxième à 10 contre 11 on prend on
prend un rouge assez tôt et voilà comme
je vous ai dit on a su être solidaire on
est resté blog bas et quand on est sorti
on a marqué voilà tout simplement dur à
l'image de notre saison je pense qu'ils
font 2/3 de but et marque le deuxième
juste après qu'on ait tiré sur le poteau
ils sont réussies pas nous et on perd de
1 voilà franchement à l'image de la
saison n'est pas efficace ils le sont
c'est les saisons comme ça c'est comme
ça après cette victoire Bailly noisy
peut toujours espérer monter en fin de
saison ce sera plus compliqué pour le
voisin FC le dimanche 2 avril voisin
recevra l’email Bailly noisy jouera à
domicile contre Le Chesnay
[Musique]
et on va maintenant parler de rugby dans
le championnat de fédéral 2 mauvaises
opération pour plaisir qui a perdu 16 à
13 sur le terrain du Rheu de son côté
Versailles n'a pas joué mais gagne par
forfait face à Domont sur le score de 25
à 0 classement les plaisirsois sont 3e
et voir revenir l'heureux à deux points
les versaillers sont quant à eux à la
cinquième place de la poule
et que s'est-il passé du côté du
football américain alors dans le
championnat de deuxième division à
casque d'or les Templiers d'Élancourt on
y arrive toujours pas les éléments
courtois se sont inclinés à domicile
contre les léopard de Rouen ce weekend
ils se sont inclinés 43 6 au classement
et 50 chinois sont toujours dernier avec
0 match gagné en 5 journées et un mot de
handball féminin à présent dans le
championnat de National de les joueuses
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux emporter une
belle victoire sur le terrain de
Hazebrouck ce samedi 25 mars les
immontaine se sont imposées 29 à 25 au
classement elles sont à la cinquième
place et peuvent toujours espérer un top
3 à la fin de la saison il y avait
également un tournoi de billard ce
week-end oui un régime est plus
particulièrement du billard carambole
non pour désigner le billard français
les championnats de France National 1
était organisé du côté de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à la Maison de la
Bretonnière ce week-end c'est Pascal
freuville le joueur de Ronchin qui a
remporté la compétition le local Thierry
Dubois du BC à vissinois perdu surface
qualificative au total 11 joueurs sont
venus de toute la France et enfin une
course cycliste à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ce dimanche était organisé la huitième
édition du Grand Prix Cycliste de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux deux cours
c'était au programme la première pour
les catégories seniors 3 et 4 access de
66 km la seconde était pour les seniors
1 et 2 access de 84 km pour accueillir
plus de 150 coureurs venus de toute
l'Île de France et une vingtaine de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les organisateurs
avaient imaginé un circuit de 3 km en
pleine ville et avait été créé pour
l'occasion avec départ et arriver avenue
du Parc on écoute les réactions micro de
TV 78
généralement sont beaucoup plus courts
alors que là on a quand même un parcours
de 3 km entièrement fermé la circulation
je pense c'est aussi pour ça que les
coureurs viennent
des bons virages pour des bonnes
relances et franchement
c'est pour les rouleurs quoi et les
sprinters c'était bien ouais le Grand
Prix de Montigny reviendra l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition et
ce week-end c'était aussi la 27e édition
de la guyancourse
347 sportifs ont terminé la Guyancourt
cette année pour le 10,7 km la
compétition a été reportée par Antoine
Rondeau des Foulées de Saint-Germain 38
minutes et 18 secondes la première
féminine 110 à loisiru termine la course
en 52 minutes et 27 secondes la
Guyancourt sera de retour l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition
merci amical et demi
golf et plus particulièrement de la
National Golf wiki de retour à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cette semaine
de jeudi à samedi les passionnés de golf
vont pouvoir se retrouver autour de leur
passion et d'un salon au golf national
pour nous en parler nous avons avec nous
Antoine Robin vous êtes le
co-organisateur de cet événement est-ce
que tout est prêt à quelques jours de
l'événement oui on est quasiment prêt on
est en train de fin réaliser les
derniers préparatifs et on sera prêt à
accueillir notre public dès jeudi matin
à 10h et il y aura notamment un immense
salon installé sur le Golf National
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
oui absolument c'est le point majeur de
cette nationale golfreak c'est un grand
salon où on va retrouver une centaine
d'exposants aussi bien les fabricants de
matériel
club butter balles équipement pour le
golf et aussi tout ce qui est autour du
tourisme tout ce qui intéresse
globalement les golfeurs dans leur
pratique générale du Golfe et évidemment
tout au long des trois jours beaucoup
d'animations des lois gagnées de quoi se
restaurer bref de quoi passer un
vraiment bon moment pour les passionnés
et en particulier essayer le matériel
puisqu'on a la chance d'être sur un vrai
golf avec un practice de très très bonne
qualité au golf national ce qui permet
d'essayer les clubs de faire des
fittings donc du des clubs sur mesure
avec avec les plus grandes marques du
marché est-ce qu'on peut dire que le
Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est l'endroit
idéal pour organiser ce type d'événement
clairement c'est pour ça que on l'a
choisi que la Fédération nous a
gentiment accueilli c'est le temple du
golf en France on se souvient que la
Ryder Cup était là les championnats du
monde amateur l'année dernière l'Open de
France tous les ans donc ça permet
d'avoir aussi deux parcours un parcours
de très grande qualité l'Albatros qui
permet d'accueillir des compétitions
avec des pros et puis le parcours de
like qui est très bon aussi qui
accueille des compétitions pour les
amateurs et pour les jeunes le samedi
matin et puis un espace très largement
suffisant pour qu'on ait donc une grande
tente d'exposition et puis le petit
Green et le practice pour tester de
façon réelle les clubs oui vous l'avez
dit vous êtes soutenu par la Fédération
Française de Golf oui en fait l'idée est
venue en commun avec la Fédération on
leur proposait de monter une compétition
un peu innovante sur le parcours de
l'Albatros qui est le parcours référence
et la réponse du président Pascal Griso
a été extrêmement rapide il nous a dit
ça nous intéresse à condition que vous
fassiez venir le salon du golf chez nous
et là on organisera la grande fête du
golf français donc évidemment on n'a pas
hésité une seule seconde pour nous
c'était la meilleure combinaison
possible j'imagine que ce sera aussi
l'occasion de rencontrer des sportifs de
haut niveau évidemment on a une
compétition qui s'appelle l'alliance
d'une de la nationale golfwick
l'alliance c'est une formule de jeu ou
un joueur pro joue avec un amateur donc
une expérience assez exceptionnelle pour
les amateurs et donc à ce titre on a
plus d'une vingtaine de joueurs
professionnels qui jouent sur différents
circuits ou qui ont joué sur les grands
circuits l'européennes tours ou le
Seigneur tour et puis des pardon des
plus jeunes également et donc ça permet
d'approcher très près dans des
conditions idéales des joueurs de très
haut niveau la plus grosse star
peut-être sur cet événement
je vais faire des jaloux si je dis qu'il
y a une plus grosse star mais on va dire
que un joueur emblématique comme Grégory
avress sera là un Grégory hervré qui a
été notamment deuxième de l'US Open il y
a quelques années et puis on a des
jeunes de très bons niveaux comme David
raveto enfin voilà je peux pas
tousseriter parce que on en a plus d'une
vingtaine mais c'est du très très bon
niveau
alors oui évidemment il monte en
puissance on a eu une naissance un peu
particulière puisque on devait organiser
pendant le covid et bien entendu les
conditions nous ont pas permis de le
faire donc la première année a été une
édition purement digitale la deuxième
année en 2022 on a eu des conditions
météo un peu particulières
la neige j'y étais il faisait - 2 réels
moins 8 ressenti donc c'était des
conditions un peu spéciales voilà et là
ça va être parfait puisque les
conditions seront bonnes et que au bout
de trois ans on va dire que c'est
l'éclosion de cet événement et ça
s'adresse vraiment à tout le monde cet
événement même si on n'est pas forcément
fan de golf oui oui ça s'adresse à des
pratiquants
réguliers classiques ou même pas
régulier qui voudraient découvrir en
fait c'est ça l'intéresse c'est qu'on
peut avoir tout un tas d'occasions
d'acheter du matériel de façon
intéressante de le tester d'être
conseiller par des spécialistes et puis
de découvrir toutes les facettes de ce
sport magique c'est c'est des conditions
très abordables et très très agréable
pour le faire
évidemment on compte bien revenir tous
les ans à peu près cette période c'est
pour nous une date idéale puisque c'est
le lancement de la saison en général en
golf c'est là que souvent les marques de
de club dévoilent toute leur nouveauté
c'est aussi une semaine assez calme sur
les sur les circuits professionnels ce
qui nous permet d'avoir de très bons
joueurs donc voilà nous pour nous c'est
vraiment le schéma idéal d'organiser cet
événement pendant trois jours fin mars
début avril tous les ans on l'espère et
bien
Merlin d'être venu sur le plateau pour
nous en parler je vous souhaite aussi
bon courage pour l'organisation de
l'événement on le rappelle la National
Golf 8 qui est programmée ce jeudi 30
mars et jusqu'au samedi 1er avril et
pour refermer cette édition je vous
propose de découvrir le portrait de
meryloquette grâce au sport cette
athlète de haut niveau de Para badminton
visite chaque année plusieurs pays son
handicap n'est pas un frein à sa soif de
découverte au contraire un reportage
signé Céline Charles
meryloquette est athlète de haut niveau
de parabadminton quatrième mondial de la
catégorie joueur debout avec un handicap
d'un membre supérieur il vise maintenant
la qualification aux Jeux paralympiques
de Paris 2024 avec plus d'une dizaine de
pays parcourus à l'année avec la
Fédération Française de Badminton ou en
famille les quatre coins du globe n'ont
plus de secret pour lui c'était cet
hiver en décembre ça se voit il fait
froid c'était à la Réunion et j'ai fait
le Piton des Neiges pour voir déjà un
jour faire les jeux c'est un truc de
dingue et en plus de faire le tour du
monde de décorer
en fait le monde quoi les gens la
culture c'est un truc de fou c'est
souvent des phrases bateaux ouais
j'adore pour la culture
sur plein de trucs c'est une ouverture
d'esprit que je kiffe vraiment c'est
trop bien
atteint d'une agénésie au bras droit
mais il n'en fait pas une contrainte
lors de ses voyages au contraire à Bali
il y a beaucoup de petites mobylettes et
c'est les choses de truc que je peux pas
faire en fait j'ai pris une un genre
d'élastique comme ça là que j'ai mis
autour de l'accélérateur j'ai mis ma
main dedans et en fait avec la pression
d'élastique ça a serré l'accélérateur et
dès que je faisais ça ça accéléré du
coup c'est de la débrouille mais j'ai
trop kiffé même si certains obstacles
s'imposent de même pour lui ou son
équipe
on était en Ouganda en Afrique et
pas d'ascenseur pas de rampe donc à
chaque petit étape je devais être là
pour soit soulever le fauteuil soit le
lever
prendre le fauteuil le remettre sur le
fauteuil parce que en fait tout était
une épreuve et là je me suis rendu
compte que c'est chiant quoi c'est hyper
galère
au niveau de la vision des gens et de
leur mentalité elle est très différente
dans les pays par contre asiatique
les pays arabes et tout donc c'est le
regard de l'handicap n'est pas le même
je pourrais pas te dire si c'est positif
ou négatif mais en tout cas il y a un
regard qui est qui pèse un peu malgré
les difficultés mériles portent un
regard optimiste sur le handicap et son
accessibilité je peux tout faire
je trouve que il y a plus trop de
limites à avoir dans tous les domaines
qui soient quand on a un handicap je
trouve quand même le monde il évolue
dans la mentalité dans l'adaptation de
tout il y a un peu de retard dans
certains pays dans certains continents
mais en général si on s'y prend un peu à
l'avance si on réfléchit un petit peu il
y a pas de souci dans sa course pour les
Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024 mais il
doit affronter une dizaine de tournois
partout dans le monde sa prochaine
destination le Brésil dans deux semaines
et on termine avec vous Miqueline ni
d'euros par une belle image oui image
qui nous vient du Sri Lanka la 23e
édition du Raid Amazon s'est terminé ce
week-end serait de 100% féminin fondé en
2001 par Alexandre deban a tiré près de
230 sportifs de toute la France
notamment des yvelinois cette année nous
avions reçu deux zibinoises en plateau
avant le départ Léa Nussa qui Rachel
Ducros et elles ont terminé le raid ce
week-end elles nous ont envoyé une
petite vidéo regardez
à des images qui font plaisir à voir je
rappelle les épreuves il y avait du VTT
du canoë du trait du tir à l'arc pas
facile et bien merci Mickaël et avant de
vous laisser je vous propose de jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
un ciel voilé dans la matinée de mardi
sur l'ensemble du territoire yvelinois
côté température il fera 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 3 degrés à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles dans
l'après-midi le temps se dégrade le ciel
sera très nuageux mais le thermostat
grimpe il fera 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 11 degrés sur le
reste du territoire et ce mardi nous
fêterons la saint Gontran voilà c'est la
fin du 7 8 merci de votre fidélité
demain vous retrouverez Grégory canalet
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]